[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
new ones in jail bird must be or she
would be at a night like this
no one of her dog nor for no cat neither
[Music]
tillu madhabs to gloomy Mott's to severe
sorry self one does ones bit so quite
there but just take away the shifting
when you more more necessities needed
tastier certainly dogs but but not
familiar yeah
the death feminine touch start
you've taken the wine from my pet bin
have them do the very bit yes well the
best is none too good for the occasion
now just just see the deep cavities were
no dogs friggin le George you're
downright Victorian you must have
cocktails dogs cocktails not cocktails
sir
yes now don't tell me that it isn't
British good the probably behind the
time I think of myself what's more I can
mix him mix is the word they tell me
they even put ice in them in America yes
well I don't think we'll go quite that
one
let's do it darling
I don't fancy freezing my day t-shape
why you asked papaw permission to come
out and play okay back in a tick
birthing
mine dubs
not a word that we haven't seen him for
the fourth night
well wrestle my boy welcome to the
family huh hello father
nasty night are they for afar yeah take
it then mutton bra hello dad how's the
old Acheson twinges this weather thank
you sir - dad the fire just one evening
with your agent male fan there's nothing
I'd like better meanwhile what price of
[ __ ] there yes dogs were shocked at that
dogs
where's the old training take mr.
Russell's coat and hat you're surprised
aren't you that I know about cocktail
you know I'd learned from a barman at
the Savoy used to live in Chicago allow
me sir thanks - but don't bother I've
got to be popping off directly you're
not stopping for dinner then I'm
terribly sorry father but when I
promised you to come I overlooked
another engagement
well it sure it's quite all right good
call only I'd hoped well it can't be
helped can it I mean to say one does
have other engagements of course I know
it seems fairly awful let's have
luncheon together tomorrow we'll have a
good old-fashioned reunion and you can
spoil me in the good old fashioned way
meanwhile as you suggest what price to
marry own cocktail gentlemen I give you
sir Gerald cottony my father and a jolly
good sportsman thank you mmm I say you
do know something about cocktails was
that chap from Chicago did you say yeah
when addy survivors
one of the survivors you know that's a
fruity joke
is your engagement tonight with that
save this scolding for tomorrow like a
good fella won't you now wish we could
talk things out together remember
tomorrow at luncheon we'll both make
after-dinner speeches right tomorrow
then
one o'clock pronto ah and now I'll be
toddling along sir if you don't mind the
night father your night my boy
mind the fog right you are
it was more like a ticket a half took
the fall that his little boy come out to
play with a little girl chuck everything
to the pigeon pile Charmin don't spare
two carburetor
[Applause]
oh please they're after me I'll explain
later my dear and care we were worried
about you
camping about in this farm why on earth
didn't you take a taxi
yes well our officers what is it come
come oh what's all this about you see
Sir we thought she was a we thought my
lord that gia that is we thought I mean
we thought that you got lost in the fog
didn't we Albert oh yes lost in the fog
that's what we thought
Magnus lost in little mister not this
young lady however my dear you should
have taken the taxi you telephoned we'd
have sent the car for you hurry now get
after this Witco knob just kept dinner
waiting and you know dogs good old dog
yeah you too quite so good old dogs
thanks so much wouldn't have troubled
you the world
good night officers you've been
commendably vigilant good night thank
you sir he's nice the general Courtney's
nice and that's thinking there was
nothing but a tow that Albert Stewart me
better rest a moment dad if you don't
mind just until Albert and his pal clear
off
sit down here
I know my purse leaked but rain is the
only thing that ever leaked into it try
one of these
probably give me the count after these
Gospels I'm used to
Oh blimey a short life and I'm anyone
mm-hm
no you're trying to thank you it was
wonderfully sporting of you to take a
chance on me a stranger off the street
oh I see that's rather than ugly way of
putting it off the streets why did you
do it well you you look lonely and a bit
frightened I mean it just happens that -
I am - you lonely and scared yeah that's
about as true as that I'm your need
rapid heat wasn't it did that thought
about the knees the Dobbs's effect who
when to factor ah
Dobbs himself I simply can't believe it
word of honour is the dinner served ah
yes hmm probative
but you're not going have you forgotten
that we waited didn't for honeymoon
Albert and his friend will be gone by
now overnight it all right I mean it
really I want you to stay in a way you
know you rather oh it to me will you
why not why not indeed you hear what the
young lady says done why not sir yeah
quite and you might just give us a hand
here let me help you with that coat nice
Thank You uncle
you-jin disappointed haven't you alright
oh not a bit of it you fit perfectly
really I don't mean me fish and chips is
more my style but I mean the lady you
were expecting to dinner but I wasn't
expecting a lady you know really as a
matter of fact I was expecting a man a
young man that I am wrong with fondo
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know to do your governor cutting it
out himself for a binge now you all know
my bar he's a man this day the trouble
he forget now it was when he was alive
he still thinks I'm a school board
[Music]
My dear I'm having coffee telling nice
try Ramona - yes excuse mr. gerald I am
Danny is he just telephone sir
oh here's yes all right speak to it he
didn't wait sir he
he gave me a message he said that he
couldn't have luncheon with you tomorrow
I see yeah thank you does
disappointed again
yeah oh by the boy but when you were
telling me about that dinner Joe I hate
to see him do it it's not the drink
alone two women you Wild Oats really
indicated for a young man but this woman
well you know he could become a really
great architect there's a touch of
genius in his drawings why do you know
even when he was a little jappy you are
fond of him aren't you
we've been the best of comrades always
and now there seems to be a barrier
between us we can't even talk things out
there are two times when no one can
advise a man the first is when he's
drinking too much the other is when he
loves the wrong woman does that bar even
a father especially a father you know
you make me feel very inexperienced as
if you do a lot more about life and
things that I know I do
a great deal more about life men and
women particularly men hmm
you might advise me might who I expect
I'm hopelessly of another generation
maybe I'm too old you oh well I'm still
young enough to falater at that who and
well Here I am going on about my travels
and usually it's the other way around
isn't it I mean usually it's the young
lady who tells the story of her life I'm
not sure I've never had any such
experience yes no you see this is my
first night it at that sort of thing it
does sound like the usual story doesn't
it back though
I've been broken and I decided it was
either that or or the bridge cool I
never could feel sorry enough for myself
to have a go at the bridge you know
that's interesting letter
and just tonight you decided to put
yourself let us say on the market I'm
afraid I have three not by long run good
because I want to make a bid for your
your services after all I did put myself
on me let us say market then and then
you'd be willing to work oh I I say I I
didn't mean that I really I I mean it's
not me you see it at least not exactly I
look here what would you do for 1,000
pounds 1,000 pounds $5,000 do you mean
it what would I do
I'm just try me
they're very rich stinger Venice
this is our this number oh there
hopefully yeah marriage they say we're
quite thank you
the young lady's waiting again all right
thanks so much man I'm it's a thank you
oh I beg your pardon I really do oh wow
whoo I'm so sorry I I had no idea that
oh come in Jerry I didn't think they'd
make bashful men anymore but they're and
you haven't said a word about this well
it's it's it's fairly breathtaking as
stunning I I mean to save you're
stunning and do you think it might catch
our young man's eyes look here my dear
let's give this thing up I've been
thinking it over and sorry old man
a bargains a bargain but you know I
don't want to put you in such a position
don't you fret about me Jerry I'm having
the time of my life and I want that
thousand pounds oh look here I'll give
you a thousand pounds and we'll forget
all about our little flop I've got to
earn that money I promised to get your
son away from that woman and I'm going
to do it I must tell you that there are
you pleased to Gerald with the negligee
oh yes I will take these and Randy and
these and this you if you don't mind no
by all means if you will have it they're
rather expensive I think well that's
rather in their favor isn't it shall I
have these sent your apartment murder
and madam to drink oh yes let me address
the heaven there comes to Bree Street
and matter to see the manager
yeah yeah thank you
Madame not knowing her own address it's
not so strange my imagine only took the
places afternoon you did the one we
wanted oh right I still feel you know I
can't understand the young generation
nine o'clock and the bright I can't even
crawl
[Laughter]
[Music]
libertine tonight my darling I love it
not too tight just a little tight maybe
another drink and you'll go to sleep I
know you
I won't take another drink solemn old
with your protein how can I darling I've
got to go in the party Oh give me the
slip but then you go on home then come
back I'll wait Nicholi who cares for
Nikolai with your birthday
I'll be back inside an hour but remember
now no more drinks hello
that's he meeting you here who are you
anyway
oh how you frightened me sorry
beg your pardon what's the matter no
plea stupid thing I'm afraid I've lost
my key it's nothing absolutely nothing
lady in distress never feel to a
Kourtney and rain I'm afraid you can't
you see oh no such word as can't just
leave it on me good old rocker jib jib
Rocking anyway good old rock no personal
favor Millie charming ladies lost her
key oh right all right
everything will be as bright as rain
ah Thank You Milly Thank You Ellie and
thank you too so much that's all right
just trust me an hour of peril regular
roll rocker jib rocker Jim anyway I
tried that once before I'd like to ask
you in but Oh would you step into my
parlor said the spider to the fly
[Music]
nice little spider though shoots five
that sorry some of the time other
engagement one does have other
engagements engagement with a lady too
but maybe I could give you a drink drink
me no don't drink gave them a solemn
promise word of honor
then perhaps a cup of coffee oh I can't
sleep a week when I drink coffee at
night hey who wants coffee anyway how
about a dash of whiskey nature's already
the very thing strange I didn't think of
that myself
this can't be a respectable place no man
much too cozy to be respectable
clever loose spider oh but I must be
toddling along engagement beautiful lady
just what I needed
what you really need old man is a tuck
in not a little bye-bye naughty loose
spider
oh I said really I gotta be getting
along
come on just a little rest old man now I
know it isn't respectable beds are
respectable oh man especially this bed
isn't it respectable wicked little
spider come on just a little red go
bye-bye go bye-bye
Russell darlings
was I fairly awful the important thing
is how are you this morning
really awful you'll feel better after
some tea and a bit of breakfast don't
you think a mild brandy and soda to be
more to the point
I seem to remember nothing except
vaguely a lost key in something about
the Rock of Gibraltar don't you remember
anything else you don't mean to tell me
well that is maybe it's not quite
courteous but Dad but oh dear not even
calling me a cute naughty little spider
did I do that
Baby Talk and what else what else
look here I mean did I that is did we
oh you mean it did you that is did we
wear my anyway
if knit the girl that's supposed to ask
that oh where am I
you're in my flat I found you wandering
about in the hallway and thought you'd
be safer here with me
was I what you what was I safe
better get into the East haven't you
what I mean didn't we
that is how did I get out of these and
into these don't blush it's alright I
weren't studied to be a trained nurse
okay you're an awfully good so I'm
afraid I misjudged I'm sorry
good heavens I just remembered I had an
engagement with the lady uh-huh a very
important lady well she seemed important
last night
awfully and she one apologizing to this
morning
don't overdo the apologies after all you
didn't do anything but break an
engagement then then I didn't that is
wait I simply can't understand why
you've done such a thing for me a
perfect stranger well I didn't do it for
you precisely and you're not a perfect
stranger I'm perfect I should say well
then we've met before somewhere mutual
friends it's too much of a riddle in my
present feeble condition you'll feel
better after a tub and a bit of
breakfast but look here I'd like to very
but I'd like to talk with you the tub
first up in your own flat then back
you're the best
Cody cat you care for that care part
oh I'd say I'd love it
what do you mean you can't put me
through pull up your socks sister and
let's hear that tinkle ring them what's
that Oh ring them again
[Music]
[Music]
oh never mind them maybe there is
another woman but I hook them they stay
hooked but you haven't seen him so you
tell me for more than a month if
anything drove Russell off it's your
jealousy it spoiled everything
it's business business of course monkey
business you have to don't know with him
my precious but remember you still have
me how can I forget it
if you do it will be just deplorable the
woman who tries to make the fool out of
me do you know what I would do no
darling how could I love anyone
look my Nicky
don't tell me you've lost your key I'll
always bless the one you did lose I hope
you always will
good heavens eleven o'clock you've got
to run along remember you're a
hard-working man don't you imagine one
can overdo this early rising very long
now like a good little boy tea again
tomorrow good night thank you
these have been great days for me
they've been great for me to really June
good night dear boy
how dare you sir at this hour how did I
know
now really Terry who else would think of
calling me at such a time I mean it is
rather date but I do so want to see you
look here suppose I bring the car round
well I could but I could wait down the
street little air might do you good
what besides I've got something to tell
you
feeling better
I'm your drive would do you good
I was tired but I'm not now
you know I feel rather guilty dragging
you out like this you needn't I wanted
to come
what did you have to tell me
all lot of things you're too sleepy now
to listen no no I'm not really
have a light sir father this is a
surprise sit down won't you
or better still let's have tea together
office sorry Mel I don't have to teach
seriously just because I'm not drinking
is no reason why you shouldn't have a
spot of the best weird attended the
truth my boy I I've been engaged
can't be helped can it one does have
other engagements of course know some
which I presume they are now now my boy
I see the scolding for luncheon tomorrow
what our fathers coming to anyway well
you see I was just tunneling by and I
thought I'd pop in and by the way cotton
says you're doing the wrong well well
the world modest old cotton look here if
he gives me the proper chance I'll put
this musty old firm on its feet
good boy
my job's about done and I think I
deserve a pat on the head really it's
only a month and the other woman's out
of it the boy is hard at work so it's
all beyond thanks
I've got night boy back and I owe you
you owe me exactly 1000 pounds you
learned - every penny it wasn't really
such a hard job
Russell's a decent boy and after all a
few Wild Oats are indicated you know the
amazing thing to me is that he hasn't
fallen in love with you I've been
careful of that
nothing I just good pal as if I were a
sister or another chap
suppose he we're in love with you it
couldn't be
you see there's another man and now Oh
shucks you shouldn't be here I never
imagined that Oh perhaps you should be
because the other man is is you oh my
dear my dear I've been waiting and
wanting to tell you work and I've been
wanting to hear it but not now no don't
it's no-go Jerry I hate to remind you
but I'm only a woman that came to you
through your mind if he could not really
heads up you see you'd never be able to
trust me you'd always wonder about the
past all men do no don't say things like
that I tell you I wouldn't care
I'd trust you in spite of anything that
happened it's too good to be true
much too good to be true oh I have a
faith my dear have faith I have perhaps
it might be
but I must go away first if only for a
little while and when I come back if I
come back I won't let you go no but I
must go and think things out away from
you in the meantime my job's not quite
done we always agreed we should tell
Russell the truth and now is the time
woman's be fair with the boy you know I
almost wish we oh don't you bother I'll
tell him but you'll take it with a smile
you see we're pals
these quiet little teeth have been the
sweetest things in my life you've been a
great pal June we are pals aren't we the
the best and nothing but look here
you're not going serious on me are you
sometimes it's hard even for pals to
talk about this that's what the lectures
I've listened to uh fire away old chum
swinging a bloomin egg
remember that first morning when you
found yourself in my bed
spare my blushes and I told you where
precisely a stranger perfect stranger
was the exact and somewhat vicious
phrase you see I knew about you though
all about you you did say you're trained
for nursing I'm sorry please go on
I knew about you because I was hired
hire to find out to get you away from
that other girl we are joking but June
who would your father
good old governor now wouldn't he though
just you're not angry angry angry
because the two dearest people in the
world saved me from making a fool of
myself I knew you take it this way I
told him you would what other way is
there
how could I be anything but grateful
when it brought me you you dear dear
June and I'll play the little joke off
on father rare old father and I tell him
about us
you know already don't you do no no oh
oh no you didn't know you know how I
love you how I worry and don't but I had
said it oh you mean you don't care for
me that way I mean
June
is there
is there someone else
forget it then June I'm sorry
awfully sorry just forget what I said
we're still pals June
it's not not him not my father
dr. noon said
half a mo Dobbs never remove the rare
old liquors
drinking Russell drinking hide scarcely
call it drinking so gerald let us say
preparation laying a foundation for some
real drinking surely you don't touch me
a mile spotted whiskey and share
everything else with your only son
gentlemen I give you sir Gerald cottony
my father and when I say I give him
gentleman I mean I give him you can have
him I don't want him what's got into you
of my boy unusual hot particle son
disowning proud father oh you're talking
nonsense Oh put your lies you've been
bleeding that you and I couldn't talk
things out well we're going to talk now
only I am going to do the talking she's
told me told me they're sneaking
underhand tricky on my boy she's told me
told me how you send it to me to make me
love her to make me wonder more than
I've ever wanted anything you love her
oh I'm sorry I didn't know yes you're
sorry you didn't know wrestle I only
meant no don't whine pop up like a man
don't mealy-mouthed me please please
believe me leave you why should I
believe you
you're a liar listen to me you've got to
listen you listen
I'm sick of Lies and sick of liars sick
of everything before me a you reformed
me you and that one you hypocrite
senia to me my own father Sonny you
don't say that bubbly word isn't it but
it fits her
the woman you picked up in the streets
nothing but a common door go ahead hit
me you've done everything else to me
it's will anyone else but my own
well I haven't the same compulsion my
father
rust
Oh
what happened
tell me Gary he's been here and he's
gone
whatever oh no no
I'll bring him back to you I he wanted
just like my own son
oh no no he didn't he didn't mean to
he's only a boy and he was hurt like a
boy he wanted to hurt someone else try
to understand you wouldn't mind of a
child in the nursery struggle that's
what it was
I'm lost man Chen
no no it can't be I won't let it happen
it has happened
and I'm to blame
it's all my fault oh I might have known
it would be like this I think I did know
in my heart but I wouldn't listen you
see
I love you Jerry and I wanted to help
you great help I've this
I I do love you
I'll always love you and I love you too
much to hurt you
you hurt me do you think I could go on
and have you remember but because of me
you lost him
it's the boy isn't it Gerry you want him
it's not too late
I'll find him and send him back to you
that's what you hired me for wasn't it
to save your boy for a thousand pounds
you just watch me on that money
hello hmm Russell why darling am I
surprised for rather you sound familiar
though just a bit tight aren't you I
thought you'd given up frisky and me
what's that a party I'm just right for a
binge where you're flat don't know about
that you know the last time you asked me
to meet you there you didn't show up
all right darling you're flat 11 o'clock
bye yes I will bye
[Applause]
Russell Russell darling surely you are
not napping here is breath Dean talk to
them our where is he
my ancient don't be so excited
calm and sweet and tight entertain me
with some of your delightful life don't
we shall sit here together you and I and
wait for him get away
take your dirty hands off alright that's
not all right I won't touch no tiny earn
your dirty wages huh no you don't you
won't took me into your place again
you're lying sneaking you listen to me
all right just Duffy got a well I won't
you here oh wait
bar me out will ya I'll show you don't
try to put on airs with me a little
[ __ ] pretending your particular comes
in here is you'll hear the kind of talk
you deserve your smirking rotten cheek
Oh laughing at me ain't you you're both
laugh at me you and that sweet sated
father of mine go ahead
why shouldn't you laugh me thinking all
the time you were everything's sweet and
clean and decent
go ahead laugh it's a joke me thinking
poetic thoughts about you about you a
woman for hire a woman with a placemark
honor and as much of a private man a
mangy alley that anybody's cut anybody's
woman
you're right Russell that's all I know
even worse oh right again but I've
learned my lesson I going away with him
naturally alone it's not that way
between your father and me don't you see
I care too much for you to stand between
your government in that's where you're
going well I'll show you now show him to
so you think I'm going to your old gent
a what a priceless Paris that had you
and your papa are me and now what's a
Gerald Lincoln cottony him pretended he
was better than the rest the only
difference was that he tried to get with
pounds what others trying to get with
shillings hmm
little Jew knees the one that got this
time I got this flat and clothes and
money all for a sweet smile and I thank
you sir nothing but nothing what did you
expect lilies of the bloomin Valley I
did your old man in the eye and he never
even blinked the dotty old boy didn't
even get so much as a lion you're here
thank you to be slinging your hook make
I'm drunk don't you maybe I am
enough not enough to let you trick me
again not as tough as I'm gonna get do
you know what I'm gonna do tonight
no cos I do like father like son you're
gonna meet that prize package birthing
wallah
up and your flat don't like that do you
why not us girls gotta live give me a
drink give you a drink
milks more your style well you're not
man enough all I ain't still reformed in
me aren't you give me that drink I won't
be here
lemme alone
don't trying to do any tricks on me oh
really alone
it's the same the only way the worms
need support what get sublime
[Music]
it's flame the whole world over is the
ball but hello mr. Courtney I say I said
it's a ripping morning sir oh yes
plain enough happened sometime during
the night she came to his flat me done
her in all we gotta do is find the lad
that won't be hard we'll have him by
night you say you saw him coming out of
his lap and he looked like he'd been
drinking that's him right enough tell
headquarters to arrest Russell Courtney
serious arresting the son of Sir Gerald
Courtney at serious to doing a young
lady in it's a clear case
well Burton till the officers will
surrender their prisoner in five minutes
now you better tell us Russell my boy we
can hardly expect further lenience from
the police they've been more than fair
and bringing you here now won't you tell
us your father and your lawyer where you
were and tell him where I was is the
only way to clear myself no matter who
else it hurts it's your only chance if I
told the truth the real truth it would
be too hard to believe tell me my boy
canter I'll understand
I'm afraid father you'd be the last to
understand the entire truth well I don't
mean to be unkind oh my boy tell me it's
our last chance
I've treated you Shadley enough already
haven't I father sorry
begging pardon sir James but there's a
young lady asking to see you says it's
very important a young lady the well sir
that is you sir
tell her to return in the morn nonsense
I say dismissal oh my dear it's good of
you to come I'd be looking for you one
night Jenny wait until you've heard what
I have to say
you'll haven't told them have you
I was certainly wouldn't trying to save
my reputation it's past saving my dear
boy you know where Russell was last
night
rather he was in a lady's apartment all
night how do you know I happen to be the
lady you mean it can't be true not you
and let me tell him but of course it's
true it was to be expected wasn't it
sorry I was afraid you take it this way
but I'm not sorry I'm glad glad to know
the truth the wedding's off they said
general can't quite stick it now can you
remember what I told you you'd never be
able to trust me oh you said yourself
that you and he we're together what of
it
where's the faith you swore you'd have
in spite of anything that's happened
well something's happened hasn't it and
worse than anything else has happened
with me me being what I am
it was to be expected wasn't it I loved
you don't you see that's what makes it
so inconvenient is the word jealous of
your own son let me tell him well I've
heard a net you'll hear just a bit
laughter Gerald and you'll listen well
yes you will Russell knew how you'd take
it that's why I wouldn't tell where he
was this righteous code that gentlemen
have marry you
don't fret Sir Gerald I'm not having any
I'm just a woman that came to you from
the street out of the fog a woman for
hire someone you could buy and did buy
but not someone so help me you can marry
you've done this for me I've done it for
me a thousand pounds you haven't
forgotten a thousand quid have you you
hired me to save your boy me astray she
alley cat and blimey I saved him I'll
take the check if you please
begging pardon sir James but it wasn't
mr. coffee who did it at all
they'd nicked a chap but sort of
foreigner that idiot Scotland Yard just
reports to pay pot a man named Nicola
rabinaw caught him in miss Wallace flat
and he's confessed her confessed that he
killed miss Waller
he'll the Scotland Yard men I'll see
them in a few moments well you're twice
lucky young man this of course clears
you absolutely too bad Magda this
couldn't have come a bit sooner it would
have saved this ugly explanation the
gentlemen's code again covering up the
unpleasant thing I'd have told him
anyway I'm convinced you would thanks so
much
I'm sorry really
Charlie I believe you are but still
sorry for the wrong person goodbye to
Gerald goodbye Jerry old man there's
just one other thing for Gerald Russell
was in my apartment last night all night
but I wasn't with him as you were sir
gerald
that doesn't change things in the least
with you and me
as for this you know I have a sort of
code to I'll probably be sorry for this
in the morning however right now June
Joe don't you think you've caused her
trouble enough father she loves you go
after her wherever she goes my boy I'll
follow
[Music]
you